[Music]
[Applause]
it's lamentable it's lamentable
Mr. Macron doesn't hear that the
people are in the street he doesn't listen
[Music]
why would that be
a way of getting things across
it is not a
democratic way of doing
[Music]
that Macron releases and with him his reform
and which finally has a real
workers' government which is put in place which
will take all the emergency measures
necessary for for the workers
it is the  right to education the right to
health and of course it comes
first with the total withdrawal of
this reform which is neither amendable nor
negotiable
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
I am I  I don't agree at all,
I don't want my son to
work, he's studied, I don't
want him to work until he's 67 or 68
since he has to get 166
quarters completed  the account you will
see
[Music]
[Applause]
the prices increase the purchasing power
decreases there it will increase the ring road to 64
years while there are many young people
who are in difficulty it is better to
leave  work the young and let
the 60 years rest
[Music]